agora bulls pessoal do vídeo é mais um
vídeo e hoje 20 que fazer é coneg nata
do papel que vocês tanto pediram para
fazer elas vão precisar de quatro folhas
a4 da emissora é e só uma coisa vocês
noite nela contra ninguém
apesar de seu papel da ponta muito
conteúdo que sustentarão não der podem
já ser imitar alguém por isso sejam
responsáveis
então bora lá pessoal primeiro dominou
foi ao meio e façam dois triângulos
retângulos para essa linha dobra trecho
para a linha do centro a impressão
estamos a fazer ouvia muito simples que
eu ensinei fazer já no canal
agora junta as duas partes usando fita
convence gemma fica transparente e quase
não dá pra notar agora usar uma régua
marca em 12 e 15 centímetros quando meu
caso agora se você quiser fazer uma
united maior em comentários de elementos
tangíveis quiserem te dá para andar
bastante como vocês podem ver ainda
sobra muito papel acrescido de cozinhar
o triângulo isósceles já tem dois lados
iguais vão recrutar dobre agora os
triângulos para fora
agora dobra desta maneira também para
dar aquele foi dormir na fila da coonai
sangue um losango
foi usando é mais ou menos com essa
aparência serão que denilson foi um
campo maior o mais pequeno não vai
alterar muito o vosso projecto ok agora
está na altura de juntar os triângulos
juntos teremos de francos do trecho sul
anfitriã e no final é só retirar a parte
da extremidade de estrelas e agora é só
fechar e já está feita e que a parte
angolana de cunene sobre uma folha maio
e recordem basicamente que vão ter que
fazer agora é esse comercial fizeram
inicialmente só que o tamanho mais que
ela eu subi para cortar folha mas vocês
podiam usar duas folhas de fazer isso só
pra não estragar as duas folhas vocês
podem portar armas e fazer dois na mesma
dois mini conaes ela como explicar isso
agora marquem e 5 e 8 centímetros é e e
corte mas se vocês quiserem saber cuidar
maior não tem comentarista part of me
agora é só juntar aqui nestas partidas
mini canais na conae principal herói em
uma folha com se fosse uma rifa para
fazer o carro prendeu no final para não
se prender dentro da coonai ver o
tamanho da vossa mão e na parte extreme
e terminal é do tube é só fazer uma
argola com vocês estão vendo agora
agora vou dar um cunho mais fundo e ao
cabo eo problema foi a uma epidemia que
ora aqui com fita para ser mais fácil ir
lá e só ir lá e final aprender para não
ser voltar
já está tudo feito agora é só encaixar
se vocês quiserem podem prender um clube
com cola para ficar melhor o encaixe só
sofia espero que tenham gostado se você
está mesmo deixe voto ainda voz favorito
e se inscreva no canal que isto ajuda
bastante a divulgação ea evolução do meu
trabalho e claro também mais sugestões
project que só deixarão os comentários
que como vocês podem ver eu faço é isso
é do braço e até a próxima etapa e é
cultivada